so sam tell us more
good morning adam with 51 days to go
until britain hosts the global climate
change summit cop in glasgow we can
reveal that ministers have bowed to
pressure from australia
to scrub two very specific commitments
from the uk australia trade deal which
is still in negotiation now you might
have thought that that was done and
dusted three months ago when boris
johnson met his australian counterpart
scott morrison but we are told that
actually some of the most difficult asks
are happening right now and it's not yet
concluded even though britain hopes to
get it over the line within weeks i've
obtained an email a leaked email from
the cabinet office a senior official
that revealed what went on last month
this said that after discussions
involving lord frost and uh
and liz trust liz trust and quasiquating
met the note says the business secretary
has agreed that in order to get the
australia fta free trade agreement over
the line dit the department for trade
can drop both of the climate asks i.e on
precedence of multilateral environment
agreements over fta provisions and a
reference to the paris agreement
temperature goals now you remember that
there was a previous cop summit in paris
that successfully uh bound the various
nations to reducing their uh emissions
by specific amounts and whilst i
understand that the uk australia trade
deal will contain references broader
references to the paris agreement it's
those temperature
commitments that will be dropped now
raises two questions one how usual is it
in trade agreements to have reference to
climate change and two why would the
australians want this dropped well
that's a very good question because uh
it was deemed important enough for
specific climate change temperature
commitments to be included in the uk eu
deal
also up until about a month ago britain
was expecting that the temperature
commitments would go in the australia
deal as well now clearly australia have
made this ask and uk ministers have
agreed to this ask for a reason
australia defends its climate change
record but many environmentalists point
out that it's quite dependent on coal
that some of its senior political
figures are less committed to climate
change than others now australia says it
will still meet its paris commitment and
has signed other agreements uh that
commit them to specific temperature
changes but nevertheless i think green
groups are extremely concerned uh
because as i say australia will have
asked this for a reason let's hear the
executive director of greenpeace john
savin
if we cannot get a rich country like
australia to take the environment
seriously to take the climate emergency
seriously then we are in really really
big trouble if the government is giving
in on these environmental regulations it
is truly shocking and it is truly
seismic in terms of the impact that that
will have chris johnson in a letter to
me and other environmental
leaders said that the trade agreement
will include commitments to all
multilateral environment agreements
including the paris agreement now the
reason why he wrote this letter was
because he was basically saying trade
and the environment cannot be separated
he said this is not going to be a race
to the bottom we're not going to
undercut regulations we're not going to
undercut the commitments that we've made
to deal with the climate emergency in
fact he said the very opposite there's
going to be a race for the top now what
this email shows is that that is just a
bare-faced lie that actually what
they're doing is the opposite this is a
race to the bottom and it is a disaster
so sam where does this leave boris
johnson and the government which
obviously want trade deals but they also
want breakthroughs on uh climate change
commitments well i think the government
are now scrambling to put a brave face
on this now they're going to claim uh
that they've secured a first when it
comes to the climate goals in the
australia trade deal they'll point out
that for the first time australia has
reference will reference the paris
agreement in a trade deal they haven't
done that
before
but the truth is that the binding
elements have clearly been dropped
and that'll happen
for a reason so
government sources to me talk about the
commitments now being implicit rather
than legally blinding and explicit i
suspect that opposition mps trade groups
and environmental groups
will make whatever they can of of that
very important uh change in language
there will nevertheless still be a whole
chapter on the environment in this deal
but it just doesn't contain some of the
things that environmental groups want to
see and increasingly australia looking
like one of the bad guys when it comes
to climate change well they say that
even though they have uh not committed
as much as some other countries like the
uk when it comes to uh when it comes to
climate change and uh
reducing their emissions there is a hope
that australia is one of the nations
that moves uh before the climate change
summit in early november uh and
increases its targets as interim targets
uh towards meeting the paris climate
change agreement we will see whether
they do that i think they would say that
you need to look at particularly the
behavior of china uh first before uh
putting pressure on countries like them
they do link the importance of the coal
industry in australia uh to jobs and
suggest that any attempt to get rid of
the coal industry or reduce it in size
would have an economic impact that they
are reluctant to hit but that debate
clearly very live in australia not not
these given recent climate change events
there like the fires